filo express
attention l'homme est il responsable de
tout ce qu'il fait oui hélas tout
pouvoir s'accompagne t-il de violence
non suffit-il d'être poli envers autrui
pour le respecter
non mais c'est vraiment un premier pas
important la nature fait bien les choses
non il ya laurent baffie en trop bien
suivi deal de constater pour atteindre
la vérité non pas du tout la liberté se
définit-elle comme un pouvoir de refuser
en grande partie oui notre liberté de
penser at elle des limites on va te
donner
peut-on être libre sans être responsable
non suffit-il d'être dans son droit pour
avoir raison non plus la morale
s'apprend tel un tout petit peu pour
beaucoup l'amour peut-il être un devoir
non surtout pas elle sonne bien de
perdre ses illusions
oui quand même peut-on être sûr d'avoir
raison
non les différences sont telles des
inégalités non non bien sûr que non
la liberté consiste t elle à faire ce
qui nous plaît non plus à la recherche
de la vérité peut-elle se passer du
doute non plus peut-on rester un
philosophe en venant la télévision oui
évidemment
et enfin ce que sucer c'est tromper